(fun music)
- "Caillou" is the worst
show, it is the worst one.
(Caillou whining)
- And we will.
- I hate "Caillou."
(sighing)
- I despise "Caillou."
- Like "Caillou" needs to go.
- Caillou is a bald little asshole.
- I mean I love PBS but
"Caillou" creeps me out,
I think it's the way he talks.
- Caillou's voice drives me crazy.
- It's like one continuous whining show.
- Whiny, whiny, "Mommy, I'm
tired, I wanna eat, Mommy."
(whining)
- We have to get him down.
- I mean I don't know why
but he is anti-authority,
he's like a rebel with no reason,
he just does it to be a (bleep).
- Like where did he come
from and who created him
and do they like him in Canada?
- I feel like on behalf of
French Canadians everywhere,
I have to apologize for "Caillou."
We will sign a petition to get it removed.
- No!
(upbeat music)